More lights,
flash photography isn't prohibited and
there was a zero tolerance policy for any
delay or disruption.
Rubin
report,
Internet
credible
Jordan shoes is backstage.
You're warming up.
Are you guys right now?
He is wrestling the 800 pound lobster.
The shit out of that thing
in preparation for you guys.
I'm very excited to be here.
San Francisco.
I was actually here a couple of weeks ago.
I was in San Francisco.
I spoke at Berkeley.
Real
higher one.
I have no idea.
I spoke at Berkeley and then I came to
San Francisco for dinner and some of you
probably saw this on twitter.
Our car got broken into while we were
here and I tweeted out a picture of the
broken glass by our car and
literally putting it into.
People were telling me all fucking idiot.
You don't leave a car out on
the street in San Francisco.
Excuse.
It's a progressive
value.
Then of course people
were telling me that,
uh,
you got to watch out for the,
the human food that you know about this.
You guys have the accurate.
There's actually an act.
And I don't want to tell you who,
but somebody under your chair right
now to be watching out for something.
Uh,
this is very exciting.
We've been doing this for a,
this is probably our eighth or ninth show
and it's just an unbelievable seeing.
See if you guys.
I do prepare you though that I was
actually not Jordan's first choice to open
the tour.
That was Kathy Newman
for Kathy.
I don't want to make it about people.
It's about ideas.
Naturally.
Jordan,
I email her.
I emailed her and said,
hey,
Kathy.
And Angst of going out on
tour 12 rules for life.
Very excited to be like to
open for me on the tour.
Money's pretty good.
If you want to join me on a tour
at Cathy wrote back and said,
so you're saying you
want to sleep with him?
There is something really cool going on.
A Nice reminder right before we started.
So did you guys see the uh,
yesterday?
That's really awesome that we're here
tonight because you wouldn't actually born
right here in the masonic
about six months ago.
Sam Harris is here and
we're here hearing arrogant,
one who came up with the phrase
on this very stage and this thing,
read this thing that you guys are a
part of it that the world is now finally
catching up on that it is real and
it's hearing this diversity of people.
We all know there's the
diversity that the left glove,
your coloring or gender,
your sensuality and all that nonsense,
and then there's real diversity,
so we've got Sam on the left and on the
right and now we have our new leader.
Kanye West.
Are you guys,
biologists and neuroscientists and all
these people that have been working on
this stuff like taking this shit.
It's pretty awesome.
Yeah.
There really is some sort of revolution
and the beauty of this revolution,
that's how it happen.
That's okay
in this area.
It's just unbelievable
what's going on here.
All of these people coming together.
There's a couple of weeks ago I had A.
I had John Casick.
I might see that
it was raining in La.
It never rains in la and I told them
dirty clothes from Ohio farmland down
there.
I've got chickens in my backyard
and I do a little chicken coop
in the back of my house because it was
raining and couldn't see the cool from
the back window,
so he just decides to walk
right into my bedroom.
Empty.
You spend a certain amount of time
with Jordan leaders in your bedroom?
Pretty clean.
Okay.
Constantly at the hotel today.
I
cleaned her room.
We had just come back from
my room was a disaster.
I just don't my bag out
there was stuff everywhere.
PC literally jumps over all
my crap all over the floor.
He's staring out the window looking at
my dad and I realize that there's a big
bag of weed on my night.
I thought I was going
to get more bloated or
kinda
friendly
hanging out with all these fingers.
The last thing I want to do is to
shut my brain off.
That would be better.
Are you almost ready for Jordan?
So when we started this tour,
we,
I said we'd done about
eight or nine these.
And uh,
when we,
when we kicked this off,
something really cool guy and I think
I'm going to do this and I think it sums
up exactly what's going on here.
And you guys are absolutely.
You were actually in the part.
So some people by the
name of the measurable Man
Right at the beginning of the show,
he took a picture with him and his
girlfriend and he sent his tweet.
He said,
it's wild to be sitting in a soul down
the with thousands of other people
waiting.
Listen with Jordan Peterson
and went in my daily life.
I act like a secret tip toe
around mentioning Jordan Peterson.
You guys look around.
We are doing,
we are building this thing.
I know you're just beginning yesterday,
there was a lot of rocket
fuel behind this thing with.
How about Special Ed?
Ladies and gentlemen in the intellectual
dark web has made town introduce the
musical style.
Thanks Jordan Peterson.
Thank
you for
them.
Thank
you.
We have the most elaborate costume.
Thank
God.
I can tell you one thing that I do
really like guideline right from the
beginning.
Whatever.
There's been something humorous associated
with what I've been doing online and
that's a really good thing.
This is comedy that goes along with this
because for them to be a comic on your
toe to anything beats that it's gone.
At least some degree health,
you know,
it's not taking itself too seriously.
The see people who've gone
through courbet shirts on steam
and vertebrates
the intellectual level of discourse.
So I have a little story to tell you.
Something kind of Nice to be today.
It's probably more relevant
to me because I'm a Canadian,
but there's a magazine in Canada
called Maclean's and they ran a club,
a hit piece on it about three months ago.
A woman named Tabitha Southey wrote,
attend.
She's got quite an ambitious
woman and she can coin a phrase.
I think he called me the stupid person,
smart person that has been better than
the stupid person's stupid person I
suppose.
But that phrase has been bandied around
on the internet sort of Ad Nauseum in
subsets in the system.
But today,
and this was.
This was what was cool because
there's been an attempt I would say,
by the people who aren't very fun to me
too is to attempt to politicize what I
attempted to do some justification for
that I suppose because I have been going
after the radical leftists
with a fair bit of seriousness,
but I think because they jumped the
political but they started to tread in
water.
It started to trend the territory that
had no business being politicized with
restrictions on free speech in particular,
but I don't regard what I'm trying to
do is particularly political and I think
that's partly because I've known
fundamentally a political figure.
I'm fundamentally a clinical psychologist
with a secondary identity as a
university professor or perhaps
those identities convenient flight.
It doesn't really matter.
It's part and parcel of the same
thing as far as I'm concerned.
What I've been focused on in my private
practice as an educator is trying to
disseminate psychological information
of the highest caliber to individuals
because that's where
clinical psychologists do.
We work with individuals
because I think the individuals,
the right level of analysis,
you know,
when I come out and see a crowd like this,
I don't see the crowd,
which is partly why I'm actually not
afraid of the crowd because I see a bunch
of individuals and you're sitting
here and when I talked to the crowd,
I don't talk to the crowd,
either,
won't talk to people in the crowd.
And so Mcclain's,
which is the magazine
that published this piece,
satirical piece on me a few months ago,
we actually took the time to send a
reporter out to a group that had been
established in Toronto,
which was a Jordan Peterson meetup group.
I guess.
Essentially it's about 50 people
or so it would meet up regularly.
They actually sent a reporter out to find
out what these reprobates interruptive
and um,
you know,
if you paid attention to the
corner of the journalism world,
that is not very happy with my existence.
You would assume that
it would be an asset of,
all right.
Essentially all male,
all angry old white because of course
that's how the radical left characterized
as people,
right?
They characterize them by gender and race
into everything becomes politicized in
that map,
which I think is absolutely contemptible,
but it turned out that 40 percent of
the people who came to this meeting,
we're women and then a very large
are you all feeling and you know
a large number of them were were children
are first generation immigrants who
weren't by any stretch of the imagination,
mainstream Protestant,
Caucasians,
and so the first part of the narrative
fell apart and then the second part in
the air and it fell apart because it
turns out that these people were getting
together to see if figuring out how they
could get the damn lights together and
they're serious about it and they
weren't getting their life together in a
manner that was designed to propel
them in some sense to a power position.
In an arbitrary dominance hierarchy.
They were trying to get their lives
together so that they can be better as
individuals so that they can
be better for their families.
So they could be better.
For their communities and they were
actually serious about it and in an age
where everyone is
cynical about everything,
it's really something to know that there
are people who are not cynical about
things that are that important and so
it was a pleasant surprise to see this
article published in the same magazine
that had played tricks with what I had
been doing before and I'm hoping that
that will continue because it would be a
lovely thing if it did.
I know from talking to people who come
to events like this that know some of you
were here primarily for political reasons,
but.
And that's fine because there's a.
it's not like the political
realm is irrelevant instance.
It's by no means irrelevant,
but I know that most of the people who
come to these talks comp because because
we're trying to do something about putting
our individual lives together and so
and that's the right thing to do as far
as I'm concerned is the right level.
Thank.
Thanks.
So I'm going to talk to you about my 12
rules for life is about but more about
the ideas in the book.
Then the book itself,
and I'm always working on the ideas and
so I use these talks as an opportunity
to further my thinking along the different
lines that I'm attempting to thinking
to make the story that I'm telling more
and more coherent and more communicable
and so I'll start with that.
I'll start with rule one.
Rule One,
his stand up straight with your
shoulders back and it contains the,
I suppose,
infamous commentary on crustaceans and
trying to make a point and I should point
out because I was making a point that
should actually be of great interest to
people on the left and the people on the
left are of course concerned with the
distance house and that's why you need a
left wing into your political structure
because someone needs to be
concerned with his house.
But what point did I was trying
to make in the first chapter was
hierarchies are inevitable and the fact
that they're inevitability is evidence
in the existence of
hierarchies in domains of life.
Far outside of the human domain.
The hierarchies have been around for $30
billion a year and there are permanent
structural elements of existence.
That doesn't mean I was justifying.
We get something that exists.
It's not going to justify it.
You took point on fit.
It exists now where the hierarchies is
it completely separate issue in public
dressed very briefly in a moment,
but
there's a moral,
there's a lesson to be derived from the
fact that hierarchies are ancient and
that is if you're a critic of hierarchies
and there are negative consequences,
you cannot lay here existence at the feet
of western civilization or capitalism
or the free market or the patriarchy
because it's western civilization.
Capitalism,
the free market and the patriarchy,
which is a word by the way,
didn't give rise to hire a consultant.
And you could tell that
because monsters have,
right?
So there's a third of a billion years
of social labs organization into
hierarchies and you can
put that at the feet of,
um,
political economic system period.
And so it's for that reason,
among many,
many,
many other reasons.
The says are wrong.
You're not wrong.
They're wrong in a way that it's going
to make it impossible for well oriented
business who were actually
concerned about the desert is acid,
let's say the struggling working class
to actually make more headway in their
attempts to deal with the
district capacity because
their underlying theory is
wrong and it's wrong
because it's not serious.
You know,
like I don't talk to you a slave.
The reason for hierarchies
isn't a negative consequences,
so we'll go through this quite quickly.
So here's a truism.
Need something to do with your life.
It's worthwhile.
You need something to
email and it's a deep true.
Is it because the creatures of it
couldn't move roughly speaking,
need something Neymat.
Every creature that moves in the
world that isn't statically place,
like a plant has to aim for something and
generally they infer an improvement in
their condition.
So every living creature that moves lived
in a value lives in a value structure
and the value structure or something like
where they are isn't as good as where
they're going to.
And so there's a Knoxville good.
That's where you are and there's a
bedroom which is where you're heading,
that's a value structure and you look
at the world through value structure.
You would happen to value structure,
but assuming that you're actually going
to move in the world and you need to
move into the world and the reason you
need to move in the world is because if
you just stay in one place
that you've died terribly,
so it's not optional to
move forward in the world.
It's.
It's necessary.
It's necessary psychophysiologic lane and
it's necessary psychologically as well
because it turns out that the way that
people derive most of their positive
emotion,
which is the antidote to the
suffering that's it taken to life,
is by naming something worth attaining.
That's where the meaning comes from.
Now,
the problem with naming and
something worth updating,
especially if you do that
in a social environment,
is that you immediately set up a
competitive under corporate plans.
We'll call it the competitive
landscape for them,
for the time being.
Because no matter what it is
that you're aiming at doing,
if you're going to do
it with other people,
some people are going to be better at
it than other people and it doesn't
matter.
It can be something as benign.
Let's say it's going to have a massage.
Massage is something that you think is
good and then that's a service that's
offered in your city.
Then there's going to be a hierarchical
rank ordering of people who are good at
being massage therapists and running
their businesses and it's not because
they're more powerful or because
they're oppressing the other massage
therapists.
It isn't that even though some of them
might be somewhat crooked in their
business events and maybe
somewhat underhanded,
no,
it's something that's massage
therapists are generally known for.
When you take the critique of
capitalism and you make it,
make it specific in that matter,
you start to see how absurd it is to
assume that the only reason that people
attain prominence in the discipline
is because of a tyrannical power and
oppression.
It's like,
yeah,
that's part of it because
every system is imperfect,
but mostly it's a matter of the mere
fact that once you caught them that
something's worth doing,
you immediately produced a hierarchy.
Now what generally
happens is the right way,
roughly speaking,
supports and promotes the
structure of the hierarchy.
He says that's a good
thing and the lab says,
wait a second.
As soon as you make a hierarchy,
people stack up at the
bottom and that's not good.
You have to do something
about that and fair enough.
You do have to do something about that,
but that doesn't mean that you get to
put the reason for the hierarchy at the
fee up,
the social structure
that you have to happen.
Now,
the other proposition
I lean forward in one,
which has also been subject to,
I would say ill informed critique is the
idea that there's a hierarchy and then
what you do is make yourself
powerful so you can find a heart,
but that's what I said.
It's not what I meant.
You will be thinking about if you think
that the only reason for hierarchies is
brute force,
because if the only
reason for hierarchies,
brute force and obviously what you
need to be is more of a decline in the
hierarchy,
but that is the case because
well structured hierarchies
aren't based on power.
Tyrannical,
pathological hierarchies are based on
power and not only in the human world,
but also in the animal world.
So this is another truth that transcends
the mere merely socio-cultural.
What I've been suggesting to rule one
was the most effective way of orienting
yourself within a hierarchy isn't power.
It's competence and its competence
of a very peculiar short.
So he might say,
well no,
there isn't just managing.
You're about to be born and you didn't
know where you were going to be born and
you want it to have the right
characteristics to seek.
See wherever you landed.
And so you could say,
well,
there's a very large set of possible
hierarchies that you could end up in and
you want to be armed with the right
properties to navigate them on average,
the most effective way.
And I think that our religious
stories have evolved,
the some of our stories have evolved to
provide guidelines about how you would
act if you were trying to optimize their
performance across the seven possible
hierarchies.
And it isn't exactly what you'd expect.
It's not brute force.
It's something like,
well,
I said it's something like stand up
straight with your shoulders back at
something like an attitude
towards the world.
And that attitude towards the world is
one of courageous confrontation of what
is coming at you.
And the posture is part of that
because this is a defensive crouch,
right?
This is a defeated posture and that's
not an effective way of negotiating
hierarchies parked because it's,
it's,
it's a shying away from the world.
And I understand that people have
reason to shut away from the world.
I'm perfectly aware of that,
but that's not the point.
The point is is that if you,
if you want to optimize the probability
that your life will turn out well,
you,
you absorber the catastrophe and you
stand up straight and you make yourself
vulnerable because that's part of what
you do when you stand up straight because
you're exposing yourself to the world
and you take on the catastrophe and the
responsibility that goes along with
it and that's by no means the same as
becoming the most powerful person you
can so you can thrash the competition and
struggle.
You're waiting to talk
in a power oriented,
dominant,
tired that's not on the same story,
but the people who are reading that who
are attempting to criticize me only see
the world through that lens and so
when they read something about about
alternative pathways to success,
which would be accepting responsibility
and also accepting your own
vulnerability and also accepting
the catastrophe of tragedy.
You've lightened again,
read it any other way that well,
he must be trying to
train many targets like,
no,
that's just not right.
It's thing isn't even close to what I,
what I wrote or what have you been
attempting to communicate with people.
So that's one.
So rule two and three I'm going to talk
about at the same time to rule two is
treat yourself like you're someone
you're responsible for helping.
And rule three is make friends with
the people who want the best for you.
And those kind of make a set.
I would say,
you know,
the other comment that people who've
been credit structuring my writing say
have,
have put forward,
I'm not complaining about this,
I'm merely observing it,
is that the rules are self
evident and it's like,
well,
it's not like I didn't
know that when I wrote
my point point,
my whole point was to take things that
were true is in the sand and think about
truisms is that they're actually true.
That's the thing,
you know,
they're universally accepted.
Their proverbial let's say,
but that doesn't mean we don't forget
why they're true or the or the now and
then because they're true,
they fallen on deaf ears and you need
to go reinvestigate the structures
underneath that.
Make them true so that you can understand
that so that you can see them with new
eyes and so that's what I
was trying to do and say,
look what these things are.
The reasons that these things happened
to be the case to to treat yourself like
you have someone responsible for helping,
you know,
that's actually not a simple thing
because it isn't exactly self evident that
people liked themselves.
No,
I mean there's some people you like
and something that you disliked.
That's generally the case and some
people just like almost everyone and some
people like mobiles never went.
It's a temperamental issue,
but as you might think,
well people are basically narcissistic
and they liked themselves better than
they like anyone else and I
don't think that's the case.
It's not been.
My experience with people certainly
hasn't been my clinical experiences.
My experience has been that because
people are more aware because individuals
are more aware of their own flaws,
that then they are aware of the flaws of
anyone else excluding the narcissists.
They actually tend to be
pretty damn hard on themselves.
I opened chapter two by describing
the fact that the typical person,
if a typical person takes their dog
to a vet and the vet prescribes the
medication,
the typical person will give
their dog of the medication,
but if they go to a doctor
and get a medication,
then the third of them won't fill the
prescription and half of the remaining
third won't take your
prescription and you might think,
well that's just carelessness.
It's like,
well,
no,
it's not because you,
you,
you're,
you won't do that for your dog.
And then one of the conclusions you can
draw from that and said people actually
like their dog more than
they like themselves.
And I actually think
that's generally true.
You know,
people are pretty wholeheartedly
affectionate white would they have a dog
otherwise?
Right?
But their whole heartedly
affectionate with the dog.
It's just a damn dog.
And if there's anything wrong with dogs,
that doesn't mean they would
extend the season itself.
And I think what you're
producing is it is a,
an explanation of why that's a bad idea.
It's a bad idea not to
treat yourself property.
And so the idea is that perhaps you have
a moral obligation to treat yourself
properly as if you or someone
you were responsible for helping,
you might take more.
What's the right frame of mind for that?
That I can say,
well,
imagine if you have a
child who's wellbeing,
you are actually responsible for it.
It's not that hard to imagine now in and
then you're the appropriate thing for
you to do as a civilized and responsible
human being is to do everything you can
to help that child to encourage
the child because that's.
That's the right phrase.
If you had to boil down what you
should do with the child into one word
encourages a really good work and to
encourage the child is to instill in them
that sense that they're fundamentally.
It's a fundamentally worthwhile endeavor
for them to take their proper place in
the world and also to recognize both
implicitly and explicitly that there is
something that the child brings to the
world that only that child and bring into
the world would be a
lesser place without it.
And that's really what it
means to have faith in someone.
And it's necessary to have that
sort of faith in yourself and,
and I need an ID detached way.
It's in the same way that
maybe the presumption of
innocence would apply to you,
which is a good thing to know
innocent before proven guilty.
It's a lovely rule of thumb and the
idea that because human beings have
intrinsic value,
which is the cornerstone of
our entire social system,
our legal system,
our economic system,
it's the fundamental cornerstone
that the same thing applies to you.
It doesn't really matter whether
you lightened yourself or not.
That's not the point.
The point is that independent of
your knowledge of your own flaws,
which are no don't matter for you,
have a responsibility to do everything
you can so that the basket you can
flourish in the best
possible way in the world.
And so that's what chapter two is about
in chapter three is an extension of that
to the social world.
I could've written it.
See,
there's this psychologist named Carl
Rogers who I really like and Rogers has
written some great things
which I'll refer to later on,
listening to really,
really practical advice
and practical advice.
It's hard to become point right because
most things are so abstracted life that
you can't just can't and you
like a guidebook and say,
well,
follow this and it's gonna work out,
but Rogers has done a nice job with that
with regards to listening and I'll tell
you about that later,
but Roger said that you should have
unconditional positive regard for your
clients if you're a therapist.
I never really liked that.
I always thought there was and behavioral
analysis of Carl Rogers interactions
with his clients indicated
that he did follow that dictate
or Oregon or that it was an insufficiently
sophisticated articulation of what he
was actually doing.
Which is a better way of thinking
about when clients come to see me.
What I think is I'm on the side of the
part of you that wants the best for you
and I have not at all on the
side of you that wants death,
destruction and or.
And there's definitely a part of you
and that leads in that direction,
and sometimes the snowbird,
well,
we parked.
That's the part that these you
to do sell both destructive,
despicable,
reprehensible things or at
least to contemplate doing that,
but also to do the like,
let's make no mistake about that.
And so I would say that you want to make
friends and this is a moral obligation.
Again,
it goes along with the idea that
there's something about you that's
intrinsically valuable,
that you have a responsibility
to act property to,
towards independently of
your feelings about yourself.
It's the same.
The same thing occurs when it comes to
surrounding yourself with people in your
life.
You should be.
You should take to yourself the right
to choose the people around you,
your friends,
let's say who are happy,
when good things have happened to you,
genuinely happy and unhappy with bad
things happen to you who are actually on
your side.
And if you have people around
you that aren't like that,
then you should seriously
consider stepping away from
them because you putting
up with the fact that they're not like
that is not in their best interests
either.
All you're doing is facilitating.
They're acting in the world.
Have an attitude that's not good for
them and not good for you and you might
drink well.
That's kind of harsh to walk away from
people just because they don't treat you
well.
I would say,
well not the first time.
They don't treat you well or not.
When it's when it's you know,
no one's perfect.
There's going to be bumps and hills
and dips and every relationship.
That's not my point,
but you know perfectly well the difference
between someone who's actually on
your site despite their faults and
someone who who really isn't in that,
in that latter category with people
would be people who are pretty happy when
you fail or don't even try because
they're failing and not trying at.
If you're doing it too,
it's a hell of a lot easier on them and
that's not a helpful situation and it's
an extraordinarily common situation.
It's even common within families.
You know,
I've seen plenty of situations where
someone within a very dysfunctional family
starts to try to put together,
you know,
in the small ways that they initially
started at all they face from their family
members is unbelievable.
Bitter opposition to any viewed as
arrogant attempt on the part of the person
who's suffering to try
to make things well.
The little of that goes an
awful long way and so well,
so itself.
Those two rules are are a a philosophical
and psychological meditation on the
the ethical obligation you have,
not only to treat yourself as if you
were somewhat intrinsic value and then
we'll get into what that means later,
but also to associate with people about
who you feel the same way and feel and
act out the same thing
in relationship to you.
It's the minimum that you should require
of the people that you allow into your
life and so that's cool.
Thanks.
Aggressiveness is because
some of you,
some of you won't be able to lead this
because you've been fortunate and I don't
mean privileged,
mean fortunate,
you know,
certain certainly terrible things happen,
have you,
but you have no idea how many people
there are in the world who have never
contemplated the idea that they might
reasonably be able to make a choice about
who they associate with in relationship
to how they're being treated.
They just never figured out without
some okay thing for someone to do.
You know what it's like.
I'll give you a parallel example.
Most people in my experience,
and this is people including my
students at the University of Toronto,
are pretty high functioning kids.
All things considered,
they've been academically successful.
Most of them are quite hard to repeat.
The vast majority of them are children
of first generation immigrants and they
have that,
you know,
that drive to succeed.
That comes along with having parents who
sacrificed a hell of a lot to get you a
university and they're hoping for
good things for you and all of that.
And you know,
one of the things I found with them
is that despite them being in that
situation,
very few of them,
by the time they were 21 or 22 had add
ever formulated anything approximating a
conscious life plan associated say with
the development of their own character,
which points to a staggering
shortcoming in an educational system of,
of a magnitude that absolutely
can comprehensible once
you start to think about
it,
but by the same token,
so they've never thought about the fact
that they could craft their life in some
sense.
You know,
that they can think about
their friendships and their
intimate relationships in
their use of time outside of work and and,
and their,
their reactors,
the reaction temptation
and how they would treat,
how they would take care of
themselves mentally and physically.
There's never been a conscious.
Things are just happening to them
instead of the crafting up a plan and a
strategy for their life.
And by the same token,
they have thought consciously about
a strategy for their social being.
It's just never come up as an issue,
but it can come up.
And why would you not surrounding
yourself with people who actually want the
best for you?
Well,
I can tell you one reason.
What
reason would you don't want to
birth yourself the responsibility.
That's the underground reasons to say,
well why would he put up with people
who don't want the best for you is,
well,
they don't make much of a demand on you.
Right?
So if you're just like limping along
through life bitter and resentful and
you're not putting your best
foot forward so to speak,
they'll forgive you for that.
But I wouldn't really that
as an indication of the
fact that they care for you.
I would regard that as an indication
of the fact that they're looking for an
excuse to continue doing exactly the
same things itself and none of that's
positive and none of it's health clinic.
Every good that has dreadful
medium to longterm consequences.
So it's not a recommendation.
It's not a pathway or recommend
rule for comparing yourself to who you
were yesterday instead of to whom someone
else's today.
Well,
you know,
back to the hierarchy idea.
So we've already decided.
I say,
I think this is a solid proposition
that if you're going to move forward in
life,
you're going to be inside of hierarchy
and the hierarchy comes with the risk of
failure and success.
And so what that means is,
and this isn't the eternal truth,
it's a mythological truth,
which is why hierarchies are
represented in mythological stories,
often outside tyrants or
canes or some figure of power.
You're in a hierarchy and because of
that you're subject to the pressure of
success and failure and to some degree
you might succeed it to some degree.
You might fail.
You know,
if you compare yourself to other
people out there in the world,
especially in our hyper connected world,
it's easy to be bitter about
your relative lack of success.
And I don't care a lot more dimension.
I don't care who you are.
There's someone better looking
at you that you know about baby.
That's a celebrity type.
You know,
we might want to compare yourself to and,
and maybe like you're doing midland
well on the whole seven dimensions of
comparison to perhaps you know,
and,
and it's easy to become better
as a consequence of that.
It's an illusion in some sense though
because it truly is an illusion,
like I've had people in
my clinical practice,
my breakfast across the entire spectrum
of human ability from people who are
sufficiently intellectually impaired
and socially impaired so that it was
impossible for them to learn how to fold
envelopes in a volunteer position and
the charity.
So that would be the low functional
end to people who run like unbelievably
successful organizations
under unbelievably difficult
conditions for very long
periods of time in a very honorable man.
And so really the entire spectrum.
And one of the things I've learned from
doing that is that people are bloody
complicated and just because just
because they're successful at one on one
dimension doesn't mean that their lives
are all rosy and perfect along every
dimension.
No,
I mean,
what are the most successful
people that I dealt with?
Someone I really admired and respected
who did everything he could during the
time we work together to
get is moderately sized,
successful business running just as
perfectly as it possibly could for his
benefit,
but also to a substantial degree for
the benefit of the people that he was
training.
One of the things that people often
aren't credited with if they're successful
is their desire to help other
people become successful.
You know,
if you,
if you listen to the
standard Marxist trope,
you'd assume that everyone who's climbed
to the top about competence hierarchy
is has a baseball bat with a
nail in it can anytime everybody,
anybody sticks off an arm
trying to also get get up.
The rung me just nailed them with it and
it's just nothing can be farther from
the truth.
You know,
the people that I've met and been really
successful are so damn happy when they
can find someone else who's young,
who's competent,
who wants things to be good that
they can lend to after that,
it's.
It isn't.
Even if they're doing it
for altruistic reasons.
Exactly.
It's the one of the pleasures of be in
a position of authority when you have
some spare capacity is that you can help
other people build their lives and it's
it's
you
have any sense at all,
really shallow,
quite to a quite psychopathic degree,
that it's much more.
That's a,
that's a source of much more deep pleasure
and engagement than the money that
you're making.
It's not like there's
anything against money.
Money is extraordinarily useful,
but to think of that as the only,
the only motivation for,
for successful people's pursuit of their
success and then to assume that that's
the only form of reward that
they get from their success.
It's so bloody narrow minded and
unidimensional that it almost the gardens
belief that people can,
can assume that it's like they never
met anyone who was actually successful.
I certainly haven't met in
a reasonable number of them.
So.
All right,
so,
so we have a problem.
There's hierarchies in.
There are people who are more successful
than you on any dimension that you
could manage and you might think,
well,
how.
The problem with that is it can make
you bitter and it's a real problem.
You think,
well,
the world is unfair.
It's like,
well,
if you had a sentence and if you took a
particular successful person and you get
a multidimensional analysis of their life,
you find that of the seven
major dimensions of life,
so intimate relationships,
family time,
use of time,
outside of work,
educational status,
health,
um,
resistance to temptation to say
there might be one or two others,
but you kind of get the idea that those
people who are successful are suffering
pretty dreadfully on at least
one of those dimensions.
And sometimes more,
you know,
and maybe they're doing
well in their business,
but they haven't extremely
ill first degree relative.
And that means both many people have
an extremely ill first degree relative,
right?
It's part of life or maybe they're married
is shaky or maybe they have a habit
of like a drug or alcohol habit that
they're having a bitch of the time I'm
dealing with.
Or they had a bad history of
abuse when they were children.
There's some,
there's at least one or
two things about delight,
ones that are truly tragic
and often far more than one.
So when you meet these people,
you think,
oh my God,
it's absolutely a miracle that you're
successful given you're stumbling forward
with it.
Again,
if you.
If you buy into the
critical Marxist approach,
you think that,
well,
there was this one percent of the people
who dominate everything that's good in
everything about life is absolutely rosy.
It's like they live in some sort of glass
bowl paradise that the rest of us are
completely excluded from
because those people exist.
It's like,
well,
if you meet people who are successful,
you think,
well,
that's actually kind of sad in some sense
because what you see is the economic
success.
Although it's nothing to be trivialized
and certainly beats the hell out of the
alternative.
It's.
It doesn't relatively feeble job of
protecting you from the fundamental
catastrophes of like,
and that's too bad in some sense because
wouldn't it be lovely if you could be
economically successful and then you
were far distant from any sort of
catastrophe or tragedy,
but you're not.
Now that doesn't mean you're not from
buffer and thanked me because otherwise,
why the hell would we have
an economic system at all?
Right?
The whole point of the economic system
is to fight for you against catastrophe.
But so,
so it's,
it's,
it's a mistake to be envious say,
because what it means is that you're,
you're looking at someone
through their very narrow lens,
you're elevating them above you on that
particular dimension of comparison and
you're demeaning yourself.
And so technically it's a,
it's a mistake,
which is why I think
envy is a real mistake.
It's like,
what am I helping you know,
the person,
unless they have to be very,
very close to you,
you know,
what do you know about their life?
It's like,
don't,
don't lead to conclusions here.
It isn't obvious to think about you have
a class on every possible dimension.
And even if they do well,
that might mean you
have something to learn.
And it might also mean that they were
the beneficiary of a province and fate.
I mean,
there is some element of luck in life,
right?
But with 70,
we want everyone to be unlucky.
I don't think so.
That seems like a bad solution.
And so and so and,
and,
and the other thing too is you actually
want there to be people who are better
than you would think because
like what the hell else are you?
What are you gonna do with
their arm or you want some odd,
right?
I mean we already discussed that.
It's like you're up,
you're up the pedicle
and all seven dimensions.
It's like,
well,
is your guns like,
you know,
welcome to the promise land.
Like you need people who
are better than you think.
So then you have something to eat.
Now the question is,
well,
how do you,
how do you aim and improvement
without calling Craig venter this?
And I would say use yourself
as a control subject.
It's sort of an idea I can write from,
from being an experimental psychologist,
you know,
if you,
if you produce two groups and
you and you run an experiment,
I'm going to do the experiment on one
group or use the other group as a control
there.
The comparison group.
But you need a comparison
group for your own project,
let's say self improvement
and the question is,
well,
who the hell should you compare yourself
to if you're going to improve and that
you have,
because that's the perfect comparison
that the guy that was due yesterday,
exactly like you has all your privileges.
He's the same guy and so I'm so.
Whatever's holding you back,
what's holding you back?
It's the same thing and
whatever opportunities are
ahead of you were ahead of
him.
So you think,
well,
I can be a little bit better than he was,
and that's a group game because it
allows you to accomplish because you know
there's plenty of room
for self improvement,
right?
You're not going to run out of things
to manage and so you get the comparison.
But it's a realistic control and
this is a very powerful technique.
I learned this partly because I'm a
behavioral psychologist in particular
behavioral psychologists
do when you go see them,
it's quite fun to be trained this way
is they take larger problems like I need
to get my life together.
I'm unhappy and miserable what
I need to get my life together.
It's like,
that's way too big a problem.
You're never going to solve that problem.
That's just.
It's too big and too many than everyone
else has the same problem and there's no
cure for it.
So it's
true to the point of being a true,
isn't it?
It's like,
no,
no.
We want to decompose that.
We want to differentiate that.
It's like,
exactly why are you registered miserable.
let's not have a one phrase description.
Let's talk about your
fiverr page description.
What the Hell is wrong with you live at
the level of details that might enable
you to actually do something about it.
And so,
you know,
one of the things I do with
my clients is if they're,
if they're depressed and anxious,
the first thing they ask them,
it's like,
Whoa,
tell me about your sleep schedule.
And a very large proportion of people
depressed and anxious or otherwise,
unless they're locked into
a fairly rigid schedule,
have a very dysregulated
sleep and wake schedule.
It's very common one,
university students for example,
so they get up at like 7:00 one day and
2:00 the next day at 3:00 the next day,
you know,
8:00 the next day,
although the 8:00 and
6:00 thinks they're rarer,
but the first thing is like,
why don't you fix that?
You'll pick a god damn
time and get up like,
like a,
like a civilized person.
Why?
One of the things you want to
do if you want to have a child,
like an infant that is
absolutely dreadfully miserable
all the time is stabilize
the time they go to bed at the time they
wake up and because the child is trying
to stabilize its nervous system,
right?
Because life is very chaotic and what
you're trying to do with the child is
provide some islands of stability so that
the child can organize it's competence
around those islands of stability
and you need to do the same thing for
yourself.
It's like if,
if things are all over
the place in your life,
then you can start
stabilizing and say like,
pick a time to get up.
What time?
Well,
how about a why?
Because that's what most people get to.
So here's another rule.
You should do what most people do,
unless they're special
person can't get up at eight because I'm
a bleeding flaming genius at creating.
I'm inventing Toronto Equations will
never say you don't have to get up at
eight,
but if you're not Michelangelo or or
Einstein was doing what people do because
they have a reason for doing it and then
you fit in the world a little bit and
it's also not such a bad thing to fit
in the world a little bit better because
it's just easier for you for everyone
else and so and then you might be okay,
so then you might take one.
I can't just all of a sudden
get up at 8:00 in the morning.
I don't have the discipline.
It's okay.
No problem.
How about you get up before
10 for like three days?
It is.
Seriously.
It's like an idiot if you have a real
discussion with someone about this.
You say,
look,
here's the deal.
I know it's hard for people
to change the behavior.
I understand that.
And what I want you to do,
we're going to figure out a plan that
will make things better for you with,
I don't want you to agree with
the plan unless you agree with it,
because what the hell is that?
We're going to come up with a
plan and you know perfectly well,
you're not going to implement it and
you're going to tell me it's a good plan
because you're too agreeable and you
want to make me happy or some bad reasons
like that.
And then we're just wasting our time.
So why don't we just assume that it's
just as hard for you to change your
behavior as it is in everyone else and
you're probably not going to do it.
And so don't say yes.
Anything that you don't
think you would actually do.
And then that's an exercise
in humility because you know,
when we tried to go to the gym
three times a week and you fail.
And so like everyone or almost everyone,
and no matter how many of those
resolutions you make a new year's,
you just don't do it.
You don't stop eating cake and
you don't stop drinking too.
Beer,
fear and all of that.
You just keep doing so.
Okay.
It's hard to change your behavior,
so I'm going to lay out a plan with you.
We'll discuss it,
and if you think that it's a good
plan that you might do then say Gif,
but otherwise say no,
what will a floor but we want to do
is aim low enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of success and in
our three constitute some improvement.
Now Carl Jung said,
modern people don't see God
because they don't look low enough,
and that's the sort of thing
that he was referring to.
It's like,
let's say you want to improve yourself.
well,
how much are you capable of,
you know,
lead from you to the Messiah one week?
No,
that's not going to happen.
Like you might be slightly
better than your wretched self,
one 10th of one percent
or something like that,
but it doesn't have because of the
trajectory is more important than the
starting place and incremental
improvements are staggeringly worthwhile.
They pumped up incredibly quickly and
it's part of the reflection of this prieto
distribution issue or price's law is
when you started improving things,
each time improved something.
You've the probability that the next
improvement will work and so there will be
improvement.
Trajectory isn't linear.
It's like this and so if you
can get the damn thing going,
which is hard,
it's hard to get those initial steps in
place that can really take off if you're
consistent with it and so what it
might mean the first week is if you're
sleeping schedule is completely awry.
Then you get up three days this week
before 10:00 and that's like 10 percent
better than the previous week.
It's like,
yes,
you've compared yourself than you
were yesterday and now you're better,
and then the next thing
I ask people is like,
what do you do when you get up?
Do you eat now?
I'm not one of those people who have some
breakfast to be wonderful human beings
that need to say,
why do I?
I've never.
I've never been hungry
in the morning as well.
That wasn't a question.
It's like I didn't ask you
if you enjoy breakfast,
that's not the point.
The point is you had to fast for 12
hours or 16 hours and now you have three
cups of coffee,
which is not a very good idea and then
you load yourself cognitively and you
just regulate yourself.
Psychophysiologic Lee,
because you hyper produce insulin.
As soon as you stressed yourself,
you take all the sugar out of your blood
and then you're basically screwed until
you sleep again that night.
And so if you're anxious more than you
want to be and you don't eat breakfast,
you can probably get rid of 30 to 40
percent of your anxiety just by eating
breakfast and you think,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
you have
to
think,
well,
I read it.
I don't like breakfast.
Like eggs.
Like who cares what the hell?
Like what kind of experiences
for.
Right.
When you probably develop the
habit of not eating breakfast,
do you haven't revisited it since then?
So eat something that's sort of protein
and fat heavy in the morning and at six
months you will start through joy it.
I thought that's a whole different issue
and then just do that three days this
week and see if you feel
better and if you don't,
well that,
you know I'm wrong and so
much for that stupid theory,
we'll try but.
And we'll try it,
but people come back.
I had one client who
was actually starving.
I mean she,
this person was,
was very nicely put together.
Twenty five year old professional woman
and all she ate was like two handfuls of
rice a day and she said,
I come home and all I can do is
to sort of fall over on the couch.
And I watched the same movie every night.
So like,
I don't know why any energy.
So I did a careful analysis of her
sleep and eating habits and I thought,
Oh,
well you're actually starving.
That's your
things.
I really liked
that job.
It's a testament to the
lack of utility of envy.
That's the first.
And it's also our encouragement to be
humble enough to make small improvements
to who you are in the hopes that that
will catch on and moving forward.
And I can offer you a sort
of a strategy for that.
This is a nice one.
This actually,
this actually works quite well and I do
lay it over to some degree in the book.
So.
So the first thing is you
might take stock and think,
okay,
well what are you doing that you know,
that stupid.
It's like you can make a long list here.
Stupid things.
I know I do that.
I should stop.
It's okay,
great.
Great.
That's no problem.
You can ask yourself that question.
What stupid things do I do that make my
life more wretched and few tiles that it
has to be okay?
And so,
and if you,
if you do a little meditation around
that and we actually want to know,
you'll come up with a list pretty fast
and it's kind of a humbling exercise,
right?
To do that.
But.
But it's worthwhile because if
your life is more regimented,
few titles that people want to be,
it's possible that the reason it's like
that at least in part is because you're
doing things to yourself
that are good for you.
And so then there's the question
that derives his therapy,
which would be,
well,
if your life is the way you want it to
be and you start doing all the stupid
things you know that you're doing,
then how much better would it be?
And the answer is you don't know,
maybe it would be way better.
Maybe it would be so much better than
it wouldn't be wretched and futile
anymore.
And so it might be worth that
might be worth finding out,
hyperventilate.
You know,
if you don't want to just
suck the stupidly it would be,
it wouldn't be worthwhile
making the effort to find out.
And so
after 20 years of teaching from
my wife to actually drink water,
okay,
so now you make a list of your
faults and then you think,
well I got you're useful
and I'm pretty bad,
but it's the.
And probably I don't do any of the
things I need to do to fix any of that.
But maybe there's something on this list
that I could fix that I actually would
fix.
And so that's like asking yourself again,
don't tell yourself.
It's like you're negotiating with someone
who's kind of fake headed and you know
I'm very well put together and you can
just tell them what to do because they're
not going to do it,
but you might go an ask them if there
was something that they would do,
what it might be,
and you can do that to yourself
and people have got this list.
Is there something on this list?
Is there some step I could take
to address something on this list?
Then I would actually take.
Then I would have answered
that almost invariably.
Yes.
I think,
well,
you know,
my,
my closet,
it's a squall of the alcohol.
I might be willing to take three of the
lowest of all pieces of laundry out and
contemplate something like that.
Or maybe I have a stack of papers guess
and this sort of strewn everywhere and I
don't want to do anything with them,
but I'll go in like a look at
the top three pieces of paper.
That's a lot harder than you think,
man.
Because you know,
you create a stack of paper like that.
You walk into the room
where that's Dr Pepper is.
You won't even look at that ball.
That's because it's full of snakes and
that's how your body's responding to
snakes,
man.
Technically that is exactly what because
it isn't the predatory detect is the
Predator detection circuit that kicks in,
that makes you don't look at those faces
and for good reason and so if you go
there and you just,
you're like 60 percent of the way to
actually doing something about them and so
you've got to negotiate
with yourself and think,
okay,
well if I've got to fix myself off
what in my current wretched state,
what small steps am I actually
willing to take and that works.
It really works.
And that's where behavioral psychologist,
no,
it's like break the dam them down until
you're willing to take a step forward on
that pathway.
If something is completely
intractable that's facing you,
you know,
decomposes and he'll just keep cutting
it into smaller and smaller pieces until
you finally get a piece.
You think,
Hey,
I can ask you that,
but that's also still worthwhile.
You can't be so trivial,
but you don't get any
satisfaction out of it,
so okay.
That's
basically it says despite your mention
present condition and your relative lack
of process,
most things you can make it like
simple enough if you think about it,
so that will probably be able to make
it slightly better and then you can
iterate them.
It's like that's believable.
It's not like you're jumping up and down
in some sort of narcissistic way about
how great you are.
It's not that at all.
It's like you're taking your
limitations and the human limitations,
right?
Because everyone's like that into account
and you're actually starting to be
willing to realistically work with them
and it really does work and accelerate,
so that's a good thing.
Okay,
so rural fire,
this is what I thought
would be very contentious,
but it hasn't been that contentious,
which actually surprises me.
Don't let your children do
anything that makes you just like,
now
I'd like to punch of fishes,
twists in it,
you know,
and one of them is just
propositions nested inside
of one of the children can be
dislikable.
Okay.
What will everyone knows that,
I mean when you were a child,
there were lots of children.
You get light,
right?
When you're an adult,
you have friends and they have
children with and you don't like.
Some of those children is have to do less
likely to invite those adults to your
house.
You won't say anything
to smile with your mouth,
but not your eyes.
When the children,
that's the same style of site uses
what it's like to be a
child and no one likes.
And then when they go and they see adults,
the adults smile at them with their mouth.
But Dr Rice.
It's like what sort of
world is that for a child?
It's like they're surrounded
by well meaning cycle house,
right?
And that's what you do to your child if
you allow them to do things that make
people dislike them.
And so that is not a good
thing to do to your child.
And so we've been,
first of all,
the children can be just like a whole.
And then we had met that parents can
facilitate the dislike ability of their
children and we admit third that
parents can dislike their children,
whose parents don't dislike her children.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
there's at least 20 percent of the people
in this audience at least have not had
a very good relationship
with their parents.
And so,
and you know,
families can be an absolute snake pit.
You're way more likely to be killed by a
family member that a stranger like way,
way more,
like way more like,
especially if you drained with them.
So if you don't want
to be killed and don't
treat them with your family,
your risk of homicide,
just stay away from your kid falls.
Okay?
So now the next
tip,
contentious proposition is that perhaps
you shouldn't dislike your children.
You Think,
oh no,
that can't be possibly cute
kids campus like the cat.
You should.
Here's why.
When you just like your children,
you should just like your children when
they're doing things that other people
would dislike them for doing.
Because if you like the video,
then they won't learn not to do them.
And then wherever they go,
other kids won't like them and play
with them and we'll facilitate their
development forward because by the time
your child about you have an over most
of the responsibility for
socialization to other children.
So your job as a parent is to make your
child likable by other children by the
time they're in fourth.
And I can tell you this too,
if you fail at that,
they will never recover
no matter what you do.
And then the experiment with clinical
literature on this is painfully clear.
So kids who are alienated an antisocial
by the time therefore there is no one
knows what to do about it.
None of the interventions
that have been tried work,
none of them.
And believe me,
psychologist,
social scientist have been hitting
this problem apart since about 19,
25.
And they've done everything
you can possibly think of.
Andy in combination and a bunch of things
you can think of and it hasn't worked.
And so there's a critical
period of development between
about the age of two and
about gauge for where you facilitate the
social acceptability of your children.
And if you miss that window,
well then good luck to them.
So in what seems to happen,
here's why it happens.
So let's say you have two four year olds
and their size each other up and there
because they're trying to figure
out what is elemental level,
the wrap and you knew you do that with
adults as you want to be with an adult
who's kind of at the same level you are
to some degree if their way to hell in
Bob you with some sphere and you're not
going to relate to them in that sphere
and if the way below
you will the same thing.
You want someone that you can kind of
contend with and so kids size each other
up.
If you're a four year old is
still acting like a two year old.
Then the other four year olds
will not play with him or her.
And then they will mature into five
year olds and then they weren't mature.
Six year olds and then
they weren't mature.
It's a seven year olds.
They'll just stay two and two that they
call them the terrible twos for region
two year olds are relatively egocentric
and so if the two year old you have a
child who's still to add for that,
that's that because the other kids
won't scaffold their development,
so it's your job to dislike your
children when they're doing things,
dislikable things.
It's your moral obligation and to correct
them so that the reason you do that is
to correct them.
It's not to answer besides your authority.
It's not even to instill a
sense of morality and the
Indians some arbitrary and
technical way.
It's simple why you do that.
Here's what you want for your children.
You want them to have other
children line up to play with them.
That's like success map
and so that child is like,
they got the kind of social graces
that allow them to go into an arena of
children they don't know
and make friends quickly.
It's like victory,
man.
You've done 90 percent of what you have
to do with imperative to manage that and
so and then,
but there's more to it to like.
One of the things I've
moved and I have no kids,
I lived in a rough area in Montreal.
We have my daughter Mikayla booster board
around this little cheap stroller in
this working class
neighborhood in Montreal.
There's lots of rough guys,
rough people in that neighborhood,
but it was such fun to wheel around
because you'd see these like rough looking
guys,
lumberjack looking guys,
you know,
a working class,
French Canadian type,
kind of tough to think like Tom Waits,
gestures walking down the street and
they'd see our girl and they're stronger
and like they,
they instantly get a goofy
grin like technicolor,
you know,
and it's so cool because what you see
is that you have to be a pretty damned
good in human being.
Not to draw up your shell and open up
a little bit when you see a young child
who's kind of open to the world and fresh.
Right?
And so you see the best people when
you have kids and if you're fortunate,
and so see that's when
you want for your kids,
right?
Is You want them to behave in a way that
brings out the best in adults and so
when you take them out
in the actual world,
the adults are happy and
they will be given a chance,
you know,
because people generally
quite positively to children,
unless the children are angels
or do something equally,
reprehensible,
rolling door and only gets kicked
because only knows this crowd.
You know that's not a good strategy and
so you want your kids to be eminently
desirements with other children,
not solving massive problems right there
and then you want them to be attracted
to adults.
So the bands of the sign with the
adults come forward and welcomes to
continually into the world and you can
actually rely on window you despite your
child because look,
we know that you have arbitrary
faults and sometimes you're good.
You're good to irritate you
because you're ignoring everything.
You should be right in.
They're getting on your nerves and
it's your plenty trauma problems,
but what was shooting that you're 60
to 70 percent put together or something
like that.
Or maybe it's higher,
a little lower,
and maybe we can also assume that you're
fortunate enough to have a partner
who's also a 60 to 70 percent put together
in a slightly different way than you,
and so the two of you together might make
a person the in the main is 90 percent
and not person that you made jointly
is a reflection of the social world.
That's what it should be
because that's what a parent is.
A parent is a reflection
of the real social,
and so if you're going to
do your children to favor,
then that joint when you and your partner
is reflects the reality of the social
world to the child.
So the child figures out how
to live in this social world.
You're not their friend.
You know?
Maybe when you're a doctor,
you can be friends hopefully you can
be friends with and it's not quite your
last friend and see him
way more than a friend,
right?
Way More and the child needs deep
reflection of the social work.
Tampered with a bit of immersive,
right?
Because if you're a parent,
you're going to be more
forgiving of your child,
then the arbitrary social world wellbeing
and that doesn't mean you forgive them
everything.
It doesn't mean that at all.
It just means that the patients you're,
you're,
you're bringing them along.
That's your cool.
That's fine.
Don't
were able to map.
So you know things that you think,
oh very happy about that you think,
okay,
well maybe I can fix that.
I can help this child figure
out how to do those things.
You can have them.
So my son was an ordinary little
pushing it.
It's like,
okay,
this definitely view in
which you didn't like at all.
He was quite fraternity
necessity.
Kind of have a little chat with him was
when he was about three and then say,
look,
you know,
you can't act like that and you can sit
here and think about it and when you're
ready to be a civilized human being,
you can come and tell me and
then we'll have a good day.
And so you can sit here and fix things
up and have a good or you can keep doing
what you're doing.
Have a wrench in the
day to make choice kid,
so we sit on the stairs or your
bath mat and I drove up to them,
you know,
two minutes later and say,
look,
are you to get off both the stairs?
He,
they was drying bonus might to control
his rage and these little kid and the
kids fail temper Tantrum,
so completely consumed by rage.
It's not easy to bring that under control.
And so he was sitting there like fighting
with his head with his hypothalamus,
this ancient,
trying to bring it under control and then,
you know,
I'd leave him be.
And usually after about five
minutes or so he'd come in.
He was more contrite.
I mean,
you know,
the attitude that we would bring to bear
then was something I'd like to right
away.
It's like he was ready to be a civilized
human being again and now I instantly
liked him because the rule was
once you get off the spirits and
you've decided to be a civilized,
he with me then I liked him right away.
It's like I'm not going to hold a brush.
That's one of the useful things about
using effective disciplinary strategies so
you don't have to hold a grudge.
It's like stuck with because it's
actually done with so he'd come and say,
well,
I want to have a good day and then we'd
have a good day and so we'll kind of
consequences of that was that we mostly
have a date and so what a deal is a
relationship that you have.
It's probably the only relationship you've
ever had in your whole life where it
can actually be almost all good if
you're careful and then only parts of the
concert.
The only consequence of that is that
it generalizes for other people,
so not only doesn't work for you
and hopefully for your partner,
but I don't feel works for
your child and other people.
So it's like,
what the hell?
That's.
That's a pretty good deal and all you
have to do is have the fortitude to let
your child know in the gentlest
way possible but effective manner.
Right?
Because you've never used more
discipline than necessary.
It's just counterproductive how to
conduct themselves in the world so that
everyone is happy with their
rep and there's zero down,
zero downside to that,
except that you have to go
off the responsibility of
actually taking a stance in
relationship to your child's behavior
and people are terrified of their
children.
Now especially,
and often we'll do that all they're
willing to risk the hammer that they might
make in the discipline and there's.
It's not helpful.
So okay.
Real
Center,
Sarah House in perfect order
before you criticize the world.
That's how that's the
darkest chapter in the book.
I actually find it engaging to
tackle dark subjects because
I've found that there's something
believable about darkness.
You know,
like if someone is telling
you a bunch of good things,
you think,
well,
what the hell do they know?
It's reasonable to ask that question,
but if they tell you about
the really dark things,
then while you already know
those dark things exist,
so it's believable and then if
they're willing to sort of confront,
those are things you think,
well maybe there's something to this,
and so what are the other chapter six was,
I've tried for many decades to put myself
in the shoes of people who have done
terrible things partner.
I've done that when I've read history,
which is pretty brutal thing to do,
but also when I read
about criminal behavior,
especially the brutal criminal behavior,
it's not even criminals.
The wrong way of thinking about.
Because you know if a
criminal robs a bank,
I think,
well they want the money.
That's sort of human.
You can relate to that,
but if someone shoots up a high school
or shoots up in elementary school,
it's like calling credit
just doesn't work out.
It's because a criminal once your car you
want your car to so you can understand
what a criminal is.
Just your approach is different,
but you don't want to
do something like that.
Young man did when he showed up at
the sandy hook elementary school,
that's a whole different issue.
The question is why people do
that and the reason for that,
it's outlined very briefly
in rule six succinctly,
is that while it has to do with the issue
of failure and the and the tragedy of
life and rule six is also a discussion
of the attitude that you need to develop
in the face of the tragedy of life.
So people,
people are bound by their
vulnerability and their.
They're bound by their mortality and
they're liable to be trained in her.
All of those things are
canonical parts of existence.
Everyone experiences them.
Sometimes it's self betrayal.
It doesn't matter.
It's still a reality of malevolence
among people is a reality of the world as
this tragedy and that,
and that's true to some degree.
Even if you conduct yourself properly,
you know,
and that's the old mystery.
Why couldn't it?
Things have to get quite a bad
things happen to good people,
which is a deep question.
Everyone asks themselves that question.
When things go wrong in their life,
especially when they've been trying
hard to set a trap and it can turn you
against life,
and the people who do these
terrible crimes so to speak,
are people who be turned against
you by and in a very deep sense,
in the deepest of all possible census.
They're turned against tax.
We in a religious sense,
and I,
I can't,
I can't take the time to explain precisely
why that's the proper level analysis,
but,
but to think about it to,
to,
to answer the question,
why would someone shoot a classroom
full of elementary school kids?
You have people weighing
me down into things.
You have to go as deep as you possibly
can into the mystery of human motivation
and the catastrophe of life
way down at that level.
That's essentially the level that
religious language designed to.
What would you say to communicate
independently of your belief in a,
in a,
in a day,
and I come,
I'm making a psychological case here.
The people who committed these terrible
crimes are embittered by lights and they
believe that just because up there and
bitter but perhaps just compiled was
determined to at least to some degree
because there's plenty of things to be
bitter about life that it's okay for them
to act as universal judge would be and
to take her revenge and that's precisely
what they're doing and I attempted to
justify that because you cannot understand
something until she could justify it
and then to produce a counter argument
and the counterargument is yeah,
life extraordinarily difficult and
people are subject to trap the tragedy of
their lives and to be trail
and malevolence all of that.
And you might ask,
well why not be bitter?
And I think the answer to that is related
to things we've already discussed this
to some degree.
What makes you think that you've done
everything you possibly could to put
things right enough so that
you're in a position to judge?
This is naturally an optimistic
question and it relates to,
as I said,
the things that we discussed earlier.
There's,
there's,
there's a,
there's a building,
there's a catastrophe built
into each of our lives.
The fact that life is suffering.
The question is what's the appropriate
attitude in the face of that,
and I would say absolutely everything
you possibly can to fit to set things
right before you dared to stand up as
the judge of everything that exists as a
temptation that everyone
falls prey to at our thing,
to be optimistic and that is things can
be a lot better than they are and your
capacity to make things a lot better than
they are is far less limited than you
might fake regardless
of your starting point.
You know when people have been
criticizing me because I don't take
hypothetically the fact of differential
socioeconomic advantage into account,
it's like,
well,
I'm not naive.
I know that some people are born with
advantages that other people aren't.
Oh,
it's complicated because advantages are
multidimensional and people generally
pay a price for their gifts,
let's say,
so it's complicated,
but it doesn't matter in
some sense because regardless
of the conditions of your
existence,
arbitrary as they are,
your best foot forward is to try to set
things right as much as you possibly
can,
and there's a.
it's,
it's and it's.
It's a courageous attitudes.
It's,
it's your willingness in some sense,
to take responsibility for
the conditions of life,
for the tragedy of life and for the
malevolence of life to take responsibility
for.
That's unbelievably noble task in
some sense because it's really.
It's really hard to do that just
because you know that you're bound by
malevolence human level.
It's in the world and you might think,
well,
that's just too terrible to bear.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's true.
It is,
but that's not the point.
The point is,
your best strategy is to voluntarily
accepted and again to stand up for your
shoulders back to Excentra vulnerability
that's associated with your big and to
do everything you possibly can do transit
to accept it and transcendent and to
work with constraint.
And malevolence in the world
I know
that might not take you to heaven
and perhaps doesn't exist
and if you don't think hell exists,
then you have,
what would I say if you haven't paid
enough attention to the people around you
be you haven't paid enough attention to
the worst parts of your existence and
see the BBC,
you have nearly enough history.
You ready
on creativity and so
if you can avoid that,
something could be something
for you because you don't
need that and it would be
something for everyone else
because we don't need that.
And I think even if we aren't
capable creative Kevin,
we might be capable avoiding.
And that would be something that would
be something to take away from the 20th
century now,
wouldn't it?
Because we generated plenty of hell during
the 20th century if we want it to be.
We could wake up enough now in the
aftermath of all that and fake.
Okay.
How about we don't do that again?
I don't think it's an economic issue.
I think it's an ethical issue
of reading the causal pathways that
lead to the horrors of Auschwitz.
Let's say reprehensible horse of a radical
African places like start with this
union.
The reason that those situations became
plausible was because of the failings of
the individuals who made up the society.
You can't blame it on the leader.
You can't blame it on economic conditions.
None of that.
It was that people consistently made the
wrong choice at an individual level and
most profound commentators
on those situations.
Viktor Frankl,
for example,
how your social,
it's all fake.
It was the willingness of the average
citizen to falsify their own experiences
in the service of ideological
totalitarianism that
turned into two countries
into help.
It was the lies that people told that
they were telling me so well that would
lead us to rule eight.
I'll skip rule seven for now.
Tell the truth,
and I think I'll probably
have with this one.
I'm
too
old.
You favorite
story.
This is
the greatest story.
So,
um,
I,
I did a series of lectures last
year on genesis friend and they were
psychological lectures or psychological
analysis of Genesis says I was trying to
move into the theological domain content.
I don't,
it's not that I don't think that that's
a relevant domain and I'm not trying to
deny the existence or or,
or speak for the existence
of anything metaphysical.
I'm not trying to do that
to people who do that.
It's fine and it maybe
it needs to be done,
but I'm trying to do that.
I'm trying to make sense out of these.
Stuart's now.
My sense is that our
deep stories are myth,
which,
which are everywhere.
By the way,
that not only encapsulated
the biblical stories.
You guys all go to movies,
you go watch the marvel superheros.
You don't think that's an anthology.
It's just because we don't
know anything about mythology.
It's like that's what it is.
You know,
when you watch Harry Potter,
here's what you watch.
You Watch,
you watch a diamond resurrected,
erode defeated fig figure of evil.
That's the Harry Potter story,
so and it makes sense to you and your
kids read it and it generates millions of
dollars.
It's like,
well,
why?
Well,
it's because it's true.
Now how it's true,
that's complicated.
That's a whole different can of worms,
let's say,
but,
but it's,
you see it as well.
The director resurrecting hero,
redeemed his father and
becomes the genuine individual.
When you go watch that with your kids,
you think,
well,
that's right and you don't care that,
no,
it's a puppet.
And then he goes and rescues his father
from a whale and then none of that makes
sense that there's a blue
farian talked to my cricket.
You don't care about any of that.
It's like,
oh yeah,
that's no problem.
I can see how that would work
because you have a mythological
imagination and it's,
it's your thought is embedded inside
that mythological imagination in the data
and that I think are
essentially crystal clear.
So.
Okay,
so let me tell you a story.
So the fundamental mythological
world is something like this,
something like this,
and you're,
you're specialized neurologically
to operate in this world,
and so part of the
world is chaotic domain.
That's why I call my book
an antidote to chaos.
The chaotic moon beam is the place that
you are when you don't know what's going
on,
but it's a place of potential.
It's.
You can think about it.
Let's see.
It's hard to explain this quickly.
Here's the way you're thinking about
this is this is how I think people work.
This is how I think that
you can understand the role
of consciousness in the
world,
so I think that we're not
driven in a deterministic way.
The way that materialistic
entities are hypothetically driven.
Okay.
I think this is what happens in step.
I think that each of us is
a locus of consciousness.
We started the act like we are in the
treat each other like we are and we assume
that we are so I'm just going to
assume that that's the case and what
consciousness does not fall prey to
the deterministic machinations up.
It's materials don't substrate,
but the face,
the potential of the future,
and to make decisions about which of
those potentials are going to realize
themselves.
So when these make.
When you think about how
you think you are like,
well,
the way you think you are is that you
get up in the morning and there's a bunch
of potential things that are arrayed
themselves in front of you and then you
decide which of those makes or you're
going to do and which of those things
you're going to call them into being an
and you assume that other people do that
and if they don't do that,
you actually get angry at
because you'd say to your wife,
say,
he said,
well,
you said you were going
to do such and such,
which means to manifest a certain kind
of potential and bring them up to a
certain reality and you
get what's wrong with you.
And she'll say,
well,
you know,
maybe she'll tell you a
reason or maybe she'll say,
well that.
Sorry,
because I know that
you were relying on me.
And so you treat people like that.
So there's a domain of potential that's
chaos and there's a domain of mortar and
that's what the chaos is transformed
into when you interact with it.
Okay?
So those are the domains.
Now,
here's what happens at the beginning of
genesis in our most fundamental creation
story,
the most fundamental
gracious towards the West.
You have these three domains.
You have the potential.
It's the chaos that goes on two fronts
at the beginning of time and whatever God
is going to think about him as the
spirit of consciousness for the sake of
argument,
he uses logos to interact with potential
and to create a habit in order for.
That's Jeff.
That's the first part of Genesis,
and so what happens is God speaks and
potential rearranges itself into order and
then go and says,
well,
that order is good.
Okay,
so there's an ethical
proposition there too.
It's a very deep proposition,
and here's,
here's something to think about.
The proposition is that if you
confront protection with the truth,
that the order you generate is good.
It's a proposition.
You think,
well,
he's being good.
While it's a hard question because it's
full of tragedy and malevolence like,
is it good?
If that's a hard question,
well,
without the malevolence
it might be a lot better.
So that's something and fair bit of
that is generated as a consequence of
deceit,
as a consequence of
deviation from the truth.
So you might ask yourself,
well,
how would things be if people did
nothing but tell the truth and that
proposition is inhibited.
Genesis is thing that it would be good.
And that's,
that's reasonable
hypothesis because you know,
when I've worked with my clients,
for example,
for all of these steps,
what I see is it the people that were
hurt the worst aren't hurt because
something terrible happened to them.
It's not cancer,
it's not an earthquake,
it's not an academic,
it's that somebody to them with attending.
And if you look at the literature
on posttraumatic stress disorder,
it's quite clear that
what really breaks people,
his betrayal and deceit on the
partner of someone they trust.
And that might be to the south,
you know,
you can do that too.
So that's no problem that happens.
So it's not a tragedy into
the World Pacific catastrophe,
even though it is a catastrophe,
it's the level of the
world that's a catastrophe.
And that's probably see.
And so the second part of Genesis has
another hypothesis embedded in it,
and now that man and woman are
made in the but you've gone.
The question is,
well,
what does that mean as
far as I can tell them?
What it means is if on
the largest possible scale
what's happening to generate
the world is the Kale and consciousness
is interacting with potential to
generate order.
Then that's reflected in the
house at a smaller level.
So each of us are also
doing that on a scale,
you know,
individual in humans and that
requires your society to assume
that you have intrinsic value.
And that's at the basis
of our legal system.
It really is.
You know,
the idea that what we're
all equal before the law,
whatever the hell that means you
have intrinsic rights unnecessarily.
Responsibilities is predicated on the
idea that there's something a little bit
so valuable,
but even the state has to
keep his distance from you.
And the reason for that is
because it was so special.
Even though that isn't part of the reason,
the reason he hasn't found its interferes
too much with the individual than the
state itself collapses and that's true
because the individual is the forest that
renews to stay and so the stage is stay
the hell away from them individually
doesn't.
Let's say it was free speech isn't
because I'm a defender of free speed.
It's because I know you haven't divine
obligation to speak your truth in the
world,
so that transforms itself into the order
that isn't good and then no one has the
right to interfere with that period,
no matter
Humboldt chapter as well.
In the spirit of improvement,
I could say,
well,
don't I can say tell the truth.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
what the hell you know,
and what do I know?
It looks like we're all making urine to
a degree that's almost indeterminable.
And so what do you know
about telling the truth?
Well,
no,
because you don't know
enough to tell the truth,
but,
but maybe you could
stumble towards the truth.
And so that's the message of
Chapter Eight will tell the truth,
or at least don't lie,
because I could say,
and I look,
I think,
I don't believe that there's
a person in this room
who
wouldn't
feel in their heart the
truth of this proposition.
There are things that you say sometimes
that you know to be true and you can
feel that.
I mean sometimes you don't know.
You just don't know what the
hell you're talking about.
You can't tell if it's
true or false or whatever.
You just here to Hampton or
chaotic or ignorant or whatever.
You just can't tell.
I'm not talking about the times when
you might be an error and don't go it.
I'm talking about the times when you
actually say something that you know to be
false and you say it.
Then the question is,
why do you say it?
Well,
part of it is you want to get
your way and achieved map.
You don't want to do the work that's
necessary to get what you need in the way
that you shouldn't get.
If you want to take the shortcut.
Okay,
well that's not very bright
because there's no shortcuts
in reality and there's
a real,
a really remarkable spirit underlying
that which is an arrogant spirit which
believes that somehow you
have the capacity to bend
the structure of reality to
favor you in a false manner and
that that will actually work.
It's like that won't work.
It's not gonna work.
You can't do that.
It isn't gonna happen.
So but the.
But there's an arrogance underlying that
misuse of language that's predicated on
the proposition that you
actually have that power.
I think that through.
It's so.
It's so unlikely is it?
That would be the case that I,
that anybody clearheaded who actually
thought that through and sees believing a
fairly rapidly,
so
true,
and you know what's wrong too.
And so what chapter eight is,
it's another question along the
lines of incremental improvement.
Try not to say things
that you know to be true.
The lie stopped going and see what happens
and then you're stumbling towards
the truth and if it is the case,
as our deepest stories indicate that,
that,
that the,
that the order that is good to end,
habitable is established by truth.
Then if you start whining and order that
you bring into being from the potential
that you can front will be
the best possible order.
It's a,
it's a.
it's an element of faith.
It's the most profound faith.
The idea would be at risk.
You have to take an existential risk
because there's no proving it beforehand.
You have to act out the proposition that
the world that you bring into being as
a of align yourself with truth is the
best of all possible worlds would say
we'll make the experiment to find
out because I think you already know.
I think everyone knows this,
that the world you bring into being as a
consequence of deceit is definitely not
the world that you wanted would have
and certainly not world you want.
If everyone is doing that because
the world you would have been,
if everyone is doing that is hell,
and if you do hit with hail,
let's say thinking about East Germany,
right?
So here's the situation in East
Germany before the wall fell down,
if you live in east Germany,
onenote was three people was acting
as a government informer to regroup.
So what that means is if you
had a family of six people,
two people in your family were
willing to do the government.
They were actively
engaged in that process.
And if you don't think that that's
healthy and you don't know anything about
East Germany because that was magnified,
say across the entire Soviet Union,
it was a 25,
30 million people by deadly.
They were dance school fraction of the
people who were brutalized and destroyed
by that system.
So it's actually this chapter because I
think that's so interesting is that if
you look hard enough at the darkness,
you start to see the light.
Because if you look hard
enough at the darkness,
you start to see what the
opposite of the darkness.
And then it's easier to see the darkness.
In some sense it's even
easier to believe in it.
But if you see it clearly
enough and you're thinking,
well,
whatever the light is is it's as
far away from that as you can get.
And when you see the Great Totalitarian
Society from the Twentieth Century were
fundamentally predicated upon the lie.
Then after go to that
support and clear stop line,
someone should mention Sandra,
one starts lying can bring down
a tyranny and you're thinking,
well,
that can't possibly be true.
It's like I wouldn't
be so sure about that.
Like the truth,
if the truth is a lie,
reality itself,
and what makes you think it's stackable.
It's not like reality is if you align
yourself with the truth that you ever
reality behind,
you know,
if you're having trouble
in your corner as probably a good idea
of the things that you're just in
an articulate manner in the west,
unabashed admirer of Western civilization,
despite
harbor pop are rapidly bringing to
everywhere in the world and saying,
going for that.
And I say 10 minutes for that is clear.
Now that doesn't mean we don't have our
problems and now doesn't mean we should
know about it because it's not like
we all generated western civilization.
It was there before it goes to the board,
so there's a lot of,
well,
what do I see as possibilities?
I see unfolding in front of us
a world that rapidly improving,
we're,
we're becoming rapidly,
insanely technologically powerful,
and it's a place of
unbelievable possibility and
potential catastrophe and I
think what we want to ride this
through property and how do we do it,
what we don't know,
because there's going to be a lot of
unknowns that come along with it and so
what are we gonna do about that?
Since we don't know what to
do about what's unreal with
and that's what that is.
We want to build ourselves as individuals
and to people who are capable of
dealing with the unknown
as it manifests itself,
and that's for life is about the book
I wrote before which is coming out in
audio version on the twelfth.
It's
totalitarianism,
malevolence of evil in the world.
And my conclusion was
get your act together.
Fundamentally,
it's like there's way more to you
than you think for good or evil,
way more had you ever forced to be
contended with and in some real sense of
you're at the center of the world and
that the dance the world on your shoulders
and it's determined by the choices that
you make and that's true for all of us
and that's why we have intrinsic value
and that's where the legal system
recognizes that and I believe it's as
true as if anything can be true and I do
think it would be a good idea if
we could consciously realize that.
I think we're at a point where we
could normally have these stories,
but we can understand what it would mean
in transformation in consciousness in
some sense,
and it kind of maturation that in some
sense it hasn't been possible before now
and so my hope for the best thing that
you could possibly hope for it because
why the hell no,
and so that's the most thing that
I could possibly hope for it.
I think that we're capable of doing it.
I truly do believe that and so
that's all I have to say about that.
That's all I to say about
talk literally for the first hour and a
half and when he said I'm going to end
with this and the entire room,
I didn't really think about
what's going on in your guys.
Thinking about what you just heard here
for the last two hours to thinking about
what you heard,
if anything about what was
on CNN for the last two hours
talking about porn star.
Okay.
The point is we're waiting.
We're finally waiting.
Guys.
I hope you could feel it
happening.
All Jordan usually just takes a
moment to just create that as neck.
I think he's probably ready.
We took questions on slido.
You guys send us the questions ready?
We do this totally uncensored,
so give him around her claws.
Jordan.
Today.
We've been doing it the other way and
see what happened.
You didn't go into beyond the
root risks is side of the state.
We got a ton of great stuff here.
Again,
this is completely uncensored.
People are all asking
about you guys tonight.
I will start with clearly what
seems to be the most important one.
When will you be doing a
new web with Kanye West?
I don't think you want to hear her.
Say,
look,
anyone who's ever heard me say finger,
I think I kind of wanted to have.
What do you think about understanding
thrown in bonus one for me here.
What do you think about this feeling?
Feeling in the room,
like the truth,
the joy that's in this
room right here about this.
What do you.
What do you love about
this whole intellectual start?
Web intake is completely surreal moment
and there's this group of people who
have risen to a kind of strange,
somewhat countercultural position of
prominence and there isn't anything about
the same except they're all,
you know.
That's about as part of the job.
Thinking about what might unite them
to the degree that that's a reasonable
proposition and I think what it is is
that they actually have respect for their
audience and
my sense is people.
I never lecture down.
I'm not trying to make things simpler.
I'm trying to make them as,
I'm trying to communicate them
as clearly as I possibly count,
but I'm making the assumption
that everyone is on board
and we're going in the
same direction,
you know,
and I think that that's a characteristic
and everyone in that group,
like if you look out,
oh,
Shapiro's,
like that.
These are people in very
different political perspectives
like Ben Shapiro and
one on for example.
It's like they're,
they're pretty much on Daniel
for political distribution,
but they,
they both assumed that the people that
are talking to have enough sense to know
just that the people that are talking
to are intelligent and awkward.
And so when I come in and
talk to a group like this,
I think are,
I'm
assuming that the best way mean
is talking to the best in you.
And that would be great.
Thank you.
I like this one.
If you were to write a work of fiction,
what would it be about?
Oh,
I started reading fiction.
It doesn't work,
you'd expect.
And so really the brutal
satirical murder registering
as funny.
It's pretty dark
for shocking.
Um,
I only wrote about,
I wrote about 25 pages of it
and are already having fun with,
it was kind of a satirical new,
our effective novel.
And then I ran into my
inlaws at Christmas one year.
I kind of forget what I'm like,
you know,
because I've used it to me,
I read it to my father in law and my
brother in law and my brother loves pretty
straight guy and the conservative guy
and in this sort of western Alberta,
Texas type tradition,
and Ooh,
it's a brutally satirical piece.
And I read it in like,
all that happened was that
there was a lot of silence.
Well,
so I think that's what happened.
If I wrote a piece of fiction,
I think that that's
what's already happened.
So I don't know if it's a good idea,
but you never know.
I might finish it sometime.
I did enjoy
this theme has been sort of an ongoing
one that had all the shows that you
foresee a way for the Cultural Marxists
and the length is to be defeated in our
culture without violence.
Well,
hopefully not precisely defeated.
I don't think it's the right terminology.
I think that the,
I think the person who
tells the best story wins.
So that's the way forward is.
When I
went on Bill Maher while back,
it was interesting because,
well I had a conversation with,
with,
with Mara,
but my book and that went pretty well
because he's kind of a free speech guy
because he's a comedian,
although he's pretty left as it is,
views and you know,
there's a bit of a tension there that
he hasn't fully come to terms with.
Most people are full of contradict
what people are full of contradictions,
but then at the end of the show they
have this extra period that's only put on
Youtube and I was listening
to the panel as you know,
thrash away trump and it's
like that's amongst gay,
you know,
like anybody can do that.
And so it's just not that
interesting to listen to.
It's not interesting to
listen to celebrities actually
have trump because there
are no more interesting than hearing
anyone else do that as far as I'm
concerned.
So it's like shooting fish in a barrel.
Obviously he has some flaws,
right?
Pointing them out.
It's not an act of brilliance.
Seriously.
Definitely doesn't mean you shouldn't
criticize your political leaders because
of course you should,
but what are.
There was a vitriolic undertone to the
commentary that went beyond trump and I
kept thinking,
well,
I'm Canadian,
so I was kind of looking at
this very sympathetic to the US.
I've lived here for seven years
and I really liked the US.
I think it's an amazing place.
So remarkable.
I
was thinking,
well,
these idiot trump supporters that you
guys are on about like that's 50 percent
of your nation.
It's probably people in your own family.
It certainly people that you work with,
they're actually not all stupid.
The hardest that is to believe because
50 percent of the people aren't stupid.
Besides that,
for the last four elections,
50 percent of Americans
and voted Republican,
but you guys are split exactly down the
middle and so what are you going to do?
Defeat half your country?
Like what?
What the hell good is that you
have to live with these people.
They're quite a lot like you.
In fact,
they might be even beat
you for that matter,
so then I think while it's
with the radical left this too,
it's like it would be better to have them
drop what they're doing and integrate
themselves back into it,
do the reasonable world and be guided in
that process and I think the right way
to do that is to tell a
more compelling story.
It's like forget about all that
resentment and bitterness and oppression,
narrative and identity politics
and racial divide and all of that,
and it's like,
yeah,
it's understandable.
There are people in the world.
We do have group identities.
Everything is divided up equally,
but that's.
That's just
no
from an identity politics
perspective was so god damn dog.
I can hardly stand it.
I'm hoping it's a better story.
The story of the individual
is a better story.
When were you running for
prime minister of Canada
pipeline
because.
Because I don't think it's unreasonable
to assume that you have a political
career in Canada if I chose to do that,
but this is pretty good.
You know,
I am a psychologist and an educated
and I am primarily concerned with the
individual and I don't think
that I could do both of them.
I don't think it's possible to do both.
I'm talking to a lot of politicians to
Canada and in Australia and in the United
States about the idea of individual
sovereignty and a both personal
responsibility,
especially for the more conservative
types because they're starting to cotton
onto the fact that
there's a market for that.
No,
for responsibilities,
but I think I'm far more effective
doing what I'm doing now.
Then I wouldn't be if I made a
lateral move into a political domain,
so I don't mind.
Thanks for the record.
I'm pretty sure if the Trudeau can do it,
you can do it.
I think of that as a compliment,
but
I did not write this one,
but what did you think of Star Wars?
Episode eight
show that.
The problem was that I have with the
Star Wars Program says this shows is that
every one of them is the same movie.
It's well known that that
Tom who wrote star wars,
George Lucas,
Lucas consultant with Joseph Campbell,
Joseph Campbell,
was a student of cardio exam.
There's clearly continual,
partially conscious
utilization of mythological
architects in movies like Star
Wars,
all the big screen in
action adventure movies,
so that sort of having this
logical substrate and you know,
I've always fail because a story to be
great has to be a great story and if it's
a great story then it's
an archetypal story.
There's no way around it.
What makes it distort so more power
to the horn with types for retailing.
The great stories of.
I've noticed particularly
a fan of star wars.
Having said that,
I mean I can't really argue with them
given the tremendous amount of effort
that goes into raising a child.
What do you think of the state
and local parenting technique?
You mean winter people should
stay at home with their children.
I guess that's the question.
That's a good thing you don't
think about having kids is that,
you know,
let's say you got 90 years,
something like that and
maybe having two kids,
maybe three,
but probably two is pretty
much the average and so
that means you have three to
six years of little kids are 48 years,
something like that.
So if you miss it,
you miss it and I would say don't miss
it because anymore than you have to the
problem.
We have a little kid in about
six months later you think,
oh,
I've always had this little kid because
he gave me kind of accustomed to it and
then I'm going to be living for very
long and you don't live very long.
Time passes.
The older you get,
the faster and palaces and your life is
not long and there isn't that much to
fill it with and one of the things to
fill it with as little kids and you'll
see little kids who paid
you for taking care of them.
They pay you by being happier than you
exist than anyone will ever be again in
your life period.
And they pay you because
they're ridiculous.
The comical and playful and funny.
There's like little kids are so damn
funny and I can't figure that out.
They have a sense of humor right?
From like eight months.
You can play tricks on them and they
laugh and I can't figure that out.
I can't figure out how they can be so
damn sophisticated before they can even
talk.
They have a good sense of humor.
They can do little things,
you know,
I'm catching onto your jokes and,
and you can play with them,
which is ridiculous.
It's something that fathers in
particular do with their children,
especially rough and tumble play.
I just didn't talk about that.
It was quite a good talk.
I think it's about the importance of
rough and tumble play and fathering.
And then the other thing that
little kids do for you is,
you know,
you get kind of jaded as you get older.
And the reason for that is
you start seeing the world.
What you start saying is your memory of
the world because that was years in the
world longer,
longer.
You build up representations of the world.
And then you look at the world,
but the whole world on the headset,
you what representation
to use and it's so.
It's like you're just seeing icons of
your imagination that that's technically
what happens and that's why things
don't fill you with a sense of wonder
constantly and there are there ways of
subverting that to the world reappears in
order to regional Gloria,
one of the things that
psychedelics do for people,
but generally as you
renew their perceptions,
right?
And that can happen in radically,
that can happen to appointments,
absolutely overwhelming,
but little kids have that psychedelic
property because when you're around the
point,
they're so completely blown away by
everything that's happening that you can
look at the world
through their eyes again.
And so that takes you
out of your cynicism.
And that's also a really good thing.
So I would say it's not so much.
Well,
you have a moral duty to
stay home with your kids,
although you might.
That's not the point.
The point is,
what the hell do you have to do?
It's actually better than that.
You know when you think you're going
to have to interrupt your career,
it's like,
well first of all,
most of you don't have careers and
jobs and more power to you,
like jobs have to be done,
but,
and then even if you do have your career,
and I know this from experience,
the probability that your career is more
important than the time you spend with
your kids.
It's,
it's faddish really small and
especially because you can,
with difficulty,
you can have your cake and eat it too.
You can spend lots of time with your
kids and you can have your career.
So I would say man,
don't mess it,
like don't mess with because there
isn't that much in life that's real and
meaningful.
And that's one thing that definitely is.
Thank you.
Actually,
you referenced Psychedelics,
the way your kind of original
maybe the next door
when we wrap this tour and then
we do like a trip with Peter said,
well
are you worried about becoming
a bit of a cult of personality?
Well,
anyone with any sense
would worry about that.
I'm so,
you know,
there's this,
there's this scene in the life of prior
window naked,
if I remember correctly,
and he's,
he's telling all these people who are
carrying his shoes and his gardens around
that they're all individuals
and they all chat.
Yes,
we're all individuals
and it's a great movie and,
but I like worry about
because
I think that it encourages
people to develop their
individuality is actually not
the way that he started calling.
You don't mind.
Yes,
yes.
I'm serious.
What do you call it?
Tight definition and there's a bunch of
things you have to do is you're going to
lead or do you have to separate people
from their families and you have to tell
them that everyone outside in the cold
is evil and you have to figure out a way
to extract their labor
and resources from them.
You have to have a
compound up in the hill.
You don't want to work to have a
well known and I'm not doing any
of that old school genuinely.
I think as much as I can tell,
I have some experience.
I really am trying to
encourage people to Africa.
I don't want to tell people how to live
apart from the fact that patients leave
the lights that are the
baskets that they can conceive,
but,
and I'm partly don't want to tell me
a little device because I don't know.
One of the things I've learned is you
don't want to tell people how to live
their lives because you don't
want to steal their from.
That's the first thing
for better or for worse,
and you don't suffer for
their catastrophes no matter
how well meaning advice
and also what do you know?
You don't know what's so good for this
person to find out what's good for a
person.
You have to listen to them a lot because.
And they have to articulate your be to
discover what their appropriate destiny
is.
And that's what I.
that's what I'm hoping
that people who did I,
I really hope that that's what
everyone in this room was eating.
And I think perhaps
that's where you're here.
Do you perhaps to be encouraged in that?
And I don't see anything about
benefits apart from the fact that,
you know,
I have a certain mode
of public visibility.
I don't see that as cold,
like I just see it as a conversation
about things that are important that we
should be attending to that
we're all participating in.
That's how I look.
Okay.
You don't want to pass out the
Koolaid like we did last night.
What do you do for fun?
Beers and hanging around with comedians.
I like,
I listen to music a lot.
I bought a car last year
that I actually like.
It's an old Mercedes.
Well it's 2017,
which is normal enough to be cool,
but you know,
it's a convertible and I liked him to
drive around in that and listen to really
loud music.
I
do hang around with my wife and my
kids who are in their twenties now,
but we get along real well in there.
Pretty Damn funny.
And,
and uh,
my son's a good musician and I like to
listen to him sing and play the guitar.
My daughter had a baby and so you're like
12.
I read a lot about my daughter
and she had a brutal adolescence.
It was absolutely unbelievably
unbearable and no we didn't.
We didn't think she was really going
to make it to her thirties and she's
better,
so
thank
you know,
I kind of think this is.
There's something about this.
It's funny
because I've been feeling.
I've had some health problems and I
seem to be recovering so accurate.
You have to go down before I come up.
Especially tonight.
I don't know what it is with you guys.
You are pretty damn positive.
Thank you.
The mood in this room is the most optimal
of all the places that we've been.
Other places were quite positive for sure,
but there's something emotional level of
enthusiasm and this crap that's higher
than usual.